hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our ed talks live
this new flavor of homeroom uh that
we're doing uh we have a very exciting
conversation with book mabry about
learning loss summer slide and actually
our partnership with nwea as well before
we jump into that i'll give my standard
announcements a reminder that we are
philanthropically funded and we can only
do the work we do through philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please go
to academy.org
donate and donations of all levels make
a huge huge difference
every dollar donated to khan academy
creates
many hundreds of dollars of social
impact one of the most scalable ways
that you could create social impact in
the world i also want to give a special
shout out
operations that have stepped up
especially during the covet crisis
realizing that as the load on khan
academy has increased by a factor of two
or three
our costs have as well we've wanted to
accelerate a bunch of programs to
support parents teachers and students so
special thanks to bank of america
google.org att fastly and novartis for
stepping up and helping us fill this gap
but once again we still need help
especially as we go into 2021 to fill
that gap
uh last but not least remind everyone
that there's a version of this live
stream that you can get in podcast form
homeroom with sal the podcast so check
that out wherever you get your podcasts
with that said i'm excited to introduce
brooke mabry am i pronouncing maybe is
it my bright or mayberry no you got it
right sal mayberry
mabry all right well brooke thanks
thanks for joining us you are the head
of strategic con your strategic content
design coordinator at
nwea and nwea is one of our closest
partners here at khan academy but why
don't we for those folks who don't know
what nwea is or what a strategic design
coordinator is maybe that's a good place
to start
absolutely so nwea is a non-profit
educational organization that's really
grounded in
our mission of partnering to help all
kids learn and so we work in all 50
states and 140 plus countries around the
world
providing assessment solutions and
educational solutions to really think
about how we can harness student
learning and grow those students as far
forward as possible
my role in the organization is on
the professional learning design team
and so
my work is really around how do we
create content that supports teachers
helping their students to learn how do
we help them
use the assessment data that they get
from our flagship product map growth but
also how do we deepen their formative
assessment practices and their
assessment literacy
so specifically around strategic content
that's really our largest partnerships
our you know we're both involved
together with clark county school
district and las vegas
and
we also work with new york city public
schools and chicago public schools so
i'm really
in there to help support our consultants
and our teams who partner with some of
our largest districts across the nation
yeah and just to you know remind you
know a lot of folks nwa they may or may
not know that but the administrators as
you just said of the map growth
assessment which 20 of all kids in
america take and if you look you know
there's been over 50 efficacy studies on
khan academy and most of them have been
using your assessment the map growth
assessment it's real differentiator it's
really the first and still the major
assessment that can measure growth so a
lot of assessments just measure where
you are or are you at grade level but
this measures where you are and how much
you grew from one point to another point
and how does that compare to how much
other people grow which is really
valuable because we know there might be
a sixth grader who started the year at a
fourth grade level and got to
a fifth grade level and they had a year
of growth but on a sixth grade
assessment they might not see a lot
likewise you might have a sixth grader
who starts the year to seventh grade
level and stays at a seventh grade level
they'll do great on the grade level
assessment but they saw no growth which
would be a problem so that's what's
really cool about the map growth
assessment and why it's so powerful to
use it for things to measure efficacy on
things like khan academy and as we just
uh saw on the screenshot we have this
partnership where now the map growth
assessment acts as a placement and a
diagnostic for
personalized practice on khan academy
this map accelerator which we're doing
with school districts like clark county
which is las vegas and many others
many hundreds of thousands of students
are now using this
inside of their classroom in conjunction
with their teachers and so it's
connecting the assessment the assessment
helps figure out what you need to work
on on khan academy and then because
everything is linked you can figure out
how much that khan academy work has
driven hopefully and we expect better
than expected growth so it's a really
exciting partnership that we're doing
together so you know we're in very
unusual circumstances right now i think
which is what month
eight or nine of kovid and i know nwea
has been studying
what the effect of covid has been or
what it could be and also how people
have been transitioning or not to
distance learning uh what what have you
been seeing both on the the research
side in terms of how it's affecting
students performance and and other ways
that people are trying to cope
well if you've read our our latest
research brief we're cautiously
optimistic about what we found you know
we we made some projections back in the
spring based on our summer learning loss
data that we have accumulated over the
years but when we looked at this fall
data and really compared what was
happening we didn't quite see the same
slides that we projected and that's
really good news
reading
was
around typical of where we typically see
students coming in in the fall we did
see five to ten percentile points
of a drop in the math area so but it's
not as deep as we thought it would be so
we really want to give a shout out to
teachers and say you really stepped up
and you really um adapted well and found
ways to lean in and make sure that that
loss was not as as large as we thought
it might be so that's the the initial
results but we do
sell have some some places where we
don't fully understand what's happening
in the data because there are missing
students we do have
about
a quarter of students that aren't typic
are typically represented in our data
not there and what we have found is
those are our students
who come from the most underserved
communities students who tend to
be students who live in impoverished
areas students who tended to start at a
lower percentile to begin with and are
students of color so we we don't have
any real
conclusions our data
is is too early right now to make any
conclusions in that area but we do want
to say that right now we're seeing some
some positives and some things to
hang our hope on but we also know that
we want to to understand deeper what's
happening in some of our and our places
where students
have tended to be underserved
so to make sure i'm understanding this
what we're seeing the at least based on
the data you're seeing the reading loss
is not as much as expected if anything
it looks like your data showing that
kids are tracking similar to what they
would have done in a normal year
math there is a bit of a regression
compared to a normal year and then
there's a big asterisk on all of this
because the number of students that you
can assess there's been some percentage
of the population whether it's five ten
percent of the population that is just
not engaging right now over distance
learning and so you couldn't assess them
right now
but there's a lot of reason to believe
that those are the kids that were
already maybe facing not as fast growth
as we would hope
the fact that they haven't been engaged
in their schools would argue that
they're probably
they're the probably the worst off in
terms of growth of their learning and
they're probably
atrophying and
because that's not in the data it might
be making the data seem a little bit
less negative than it might be
that is very possible and that's that's
absolutely where we're standing right
now and hoping that we'll have a more
complete data set um as we progress
through the year
are you seeing that are you seeing that
you know this five or ten percent of
students that have just not been showing
up are are districts getting better at
finding them when you do your january
map growth administration do you think
you're going to get more of those kids
in in the assessment
well i think it's that but it's also
some of our partners decided not to test
remotely they were busy trying to
uplevel their remote instruction
and justin feel that they were ready to
administer the test remotely we had a
large turnout for remote testing but we
did have fewer
districts who made a choice not to test
their whole district but you're right
there is a percentage of students out
there who have not been engaged in
school and have not obviously been
engaged in the assessment portion too
and i think anecdotally you know we're
hearing from organizations that there's
a real struggle i think the the
technological struggle if you look at
how we've we've defined interrupted
learning
to be about the physical space the
technological space um the social
emotional um
you know the the cognitive but
that technological divide is real in
our country and so i know that that is
certainly something that the district
that that my son belongs to
i know that i have teacher friends
who've said that they have difficulty
getting a hold of students and
students have difficulty accessing
internet so i think that there are a
number of things that are happening that
are preventing those pieces but we
really have to lean in and figure out
how we can address those systemic
inequities in the platforms and tools
that students have access to if we're
going to continue this remote learning
and so the sense is maybe the january
administration at least more schools
will be ready to do this type of
administration
we still don't know what might happen
with some of the kids who've who've
disengaged and that's that's kind of
a deeper problem that everyone is
everyone is facing right now
you know what what are the things
outside you just mentioned essentially
the digital divide access you know how
that's a clear issue that we've talked a
lot about on this forum um
what what are the other things that
you're seeing that are
really tough for the education system
right now and what are you seeing that
might be categorized to silver linings
yeah
i think one of the challenges that we
often hear from the partners that we
work with teachers who are in the field
when we're doing our workshops is they
often talk about
the way the day is structured
when you're in the physical space in the
classroom it is so much easier to be
able to run your small groups and to be
able to
bounce around to the different
students who need you and when you're in
that virtual space it is much more
challenging and especially when you
think about
the kinds of tools that we have and
whether or not we're teaching whole
group or small group and how you have
that set up for your students to meet
so i think that the scheduling is one
thing that has certainly presented
a challenge to teachers
and i think the other piece is
engagement really looking at
um
we're asking our students and our
teachers to engage in ways that haven't
been the norm and so there's this
comfort level that we also have to
address in this school climate and
community it's one thing to build
community
when you're in person with all of your
learners but to build community when
everyone is sitting behind a screen and
trying to facilitate those connections
presents a totally different challenge
and i think the silver lining there is
that what we're finding is that those in
person techniques um work
virtually as well with some with
obviously some modifications but the the
premise of creating that strong
connected learning team
is still the same thing that
that we want to go for and so that we
know
that the foundation of all learning is
strong relationships and i'm hearing
teachers say over and over um
the return on investment that i'm
getting for the way that we're building
community and climate is really paying
off and now i can really dive into some
of those deeper learning pieces
so teachers are really investing on this
you know they're on video conference
whatever but they're making sure that
there's time for them to get to know
each other build trust between the
students and the teachers and the
students with each other and that's
what's one of the things that's paying
dividends which which makes a ton of
sense are you seeing
pockets of of teachers doing things
exceptionally well right now
do you think there's certain elements of
what's going on right now that we should
try to retain post covid
know one of the things that i think
really stands out is there's been so
much student choice and voice that i've
seen in my own son's education as he has
he's been remote for part of the school
year as well and when i'm talking to
teachers
across the the country when i'm when i'm
partnering
so i think one of the
the silver linings here is that um
education doesn't have to look the same
that it always has and i think we've
been given this
opportunity to innovate and to see
things differently and to know that
perhaps when we come back to the brick
and mortar in a more permanent way that
we can continue to honor the the choice
and voice that we've allowed students to
have and really empower student-directed
and self-regulated learning in a way
that continues to meet students where
they are but also gives them that
motivational factor to engage in ways
that maybe they haven't before and i
think that's the really exciting piece
that i'm seeing is that a lot of
teachers are saying you know what
we're learning some really good lessons
about what works for students and we
want to make sure that we want to
capitalize on these and continue these
practices when we get back to what used
to be the normal way
so there's a sense that you know some of
what covets done is it's
maybe unbundled or personalized
experience a little bit more whether
it's the teachers doing it or sometimes
families have done it on their own and
uh and obviously i believe strongly in
this as well if we can keep a lot more
of that momentum around personalizing to
the needs of students uh allowing them
to fill in gaps learn that they're yeah
i know you've written a lot about you
know the zone of proximal development
which you know it's just the idea that
you should be learning the things that
are just ready for you to learn
not too easy for you not too hard just
just just right um
you know i'm curious about the
assessment
you know
i think a lot of folks especially people
who aren't super deep in the education
world might be confused like there's so
many assessments you know we have
interim assessments which is what a map
growth is which can measure growth you
do it three times a year uh then you
have your state assessments uh which are
usually done at the end of the year and
kind of give a sense and and the state
assessments are oftentimes the things
that are used to
uh you know measure
school performance and all of that
one i'm curious how you
would tell everyone listening you know
how do these assessments fit together
and where do you think assessment is
going to go you know you all have been
doing digital administration of the
assessment because you well it's always
been digital but you've had to do
distance administration of the
assessment this year because of kovid do
you think some of that's going to stick
what's assessment going to look like in
five years
that's a really great question and i
think that it's something that we're
constantly thinking about too um you
know we were one of the first
organizations to ramp up and and offer
our partners the opportunity to assess
remotely we we know how valuable the
assessment is because as you said
um an interim assessment is really a
snapshot in time and um i like to think
of those i used to say polaroids sal but
um some of my the teachers i'm working
with are getting younger younger and
younger so i have to say like it's an
instagram post right so you line up
three instagram posts and you can look
at changes over time
but at that snapshot in time we can
really see where students ready to learn
relative to what i'm trying to teach
and so when you think about map growth
in that interim space we're an
instructional readiness assessment not a
mastery assessment which is what your
state summatives are state summatives
are mastery assessments when we look at
giving a mastery test to students
we're looking at them to get high levels
of accuracy so as many write as they can
because a mastery test is all about
certifying what you know and can do
relative to the standards that are being
assessed an instructional readiness
instrument which is what map growth is
is the opposite of that we're actually
looking for every single student to get
about half the items right
um and people that blows their minds
they're like why would you design a test
where students are only going to get
about 50 right
that's where the zone of proximal
development is
when we think about instructional
readiness what we're really trying to
find is um
not high levels of mastery and not low
levels where they have no background
knowledge we're trying to find that
sweet spot right in the middle where
they have some background knowledge but
mastery hasn't emerged yet so we can use
that information to create a plan a
pathway forward to mastery because what
we know from lev vygotsky's work which
is
where we got this idea of the zone of
proximal development is that when we
teach in that zone what we're doing is
we're helping move a student from where
they
are closing that metaphorical gap
between what they can do and what they
can't do yet
and so with an interim assessment we
at nwea have linking studies
where we look at a group of students in
a state who've taken both the state
summative and map growth assessment and
we do a correlational study where we can
see if this is how they score on map
growth how do they tend to score on the
state assessment and then we can provide
information to teachers to help them
understand based on a student's map
growth score what kind of trajectory
they're on relative to that state
summative so in a way the
map growth interim assessment becomes a
predictor where i can use that
information to change a student's
trajectory so the interim assessment is
is such that it helps us to monitor
growth as you said but i like to think
about how john hattie talks about
assessment and he says we should look at
assessment as information about our
impact
and so if a student is growing we really
need to figure out what is it that we're
doing that's helping get that growth and
how can i replicate that with more and
more students but if the growth isn't
there why not what are those factors
that are preventing
the most growth possible forward and how
can we really get in there and
change up things before we get to that
state summative so if you think about
balanced assessment system
we need summative assessments to
understand how students are performing
relative to those grade level
expectations we need interim assessments
that help us monitor progress along the
way but it's really formative assessment
practice that drives our day-to-day
instruction and so that's
one thing that doesn't get spoken about
enough when people talk about nwea
because they're so familiar with our
flagship product map growth
that
that they don't realize how deep we are
in the formative assessment space and so
that's where we really get in there and
help teachers think about their
instructional practices and what am i
going to do with that data that i get
from map growth and my classroom
formative data to keep that learning
moving forward every day between interim
assessments so it's a it's the macro
down to the micro
you know it's what's interesting i know
we've talked a lot about this as we're
kind of visioning the future uh you know
you're using the interim assessment and
just explain to folks why you you
actually need kids to get things wrong
is that you're zeroing in it adapts you
know you might start a student at a
let's say they're a sixth grade student
you might start them at a fourth grade
concept if they get it right you can
give them a little harder concept little
harder maybe you're getting to more
advanced sixth grade type concept but
then they get something wrong and then
they get and then you um you give them
an easier question and then they get a
few right then they get something wrong
so you're zeroing in on exactly where
that that learning edge is that zone of
proximal development and that's also
what allows you to measure growth beyond
just one grade level uh and to your
point there's formative and you know
these when i first learned these words i
was like wow there's a lot of types of
assessments but formative is really just
another way of saying assessment in the
spirit of helping you learn how well
the
the kids are learning in the moment so
that the teachers uh or whoever else is
trying to even the students can better
diagnose what can extra can be done to
make sure they're learning it well and
what's interesting with the map
accelerator that we're doing together
obviously use the interim assessment to
figure out a personalized learning plan
that the student is ready for but then
while they're practicing
uh using the map accelerator on khan
academy
that actually also helps the teacher
inform the teacher on what they need
help in so it is doing some of this kind
of a shorter cycle loop and then
you know every three or four months you
then get another interim assessment to
understand uh overall how much that's
been driving the growth and then you can
re-place i say that not replace replace
uh
uh uh students again i mean it's a
fascinating space of where we're going
with assessment you know what we're
getting a bunch of questions um here
one is
well you know there's there's families
that are worried about actually there
was a question where it went about
um
parents uh with with students you know
there's reports that we're seeing an
unusual number of kids who are failing
this year even kids who you know
typically were getting a's and b's
before
any advice you would have for parents
and i guess a broader question and
students and teachers um is you know how
do we keep the kids engaged right now
and how do we keep their motivation high
so that so that these types of things
don't happen
boy what a loaded question sal um i have
some really strong feelings about grades
and i i think that that's the first
question that you have to ask what is
that grade measuring is that grade
measuring
progress toward mastery in the subject
or is it measuring um completion of
assignments and so really having
conversations about what grades mean
with teachers is i think really
important and that's the place that
teachers can create clarity with their
students and with the families that they
serve is to really help them understand
what a grade means and what they're
trying to collect and
to
oh so that's one piece but
there's the motivational piece our
students have to understand um and this
is part of that formative assessment
cycle what it is that our expectations
are so what are we aiming for
in the learning and really give them a
pathway for understanding where we're
going but also understanding where they
are relative to where we're trying to go
and then strategies for closing the gap
between those two things
and i think when students are empowered
to see the trajectory they're empowered
to figure out where they are and then
they get the supportive
practices in the classroom supportive
assignments scaffolding if you will i've
written extensively about that on our
nwea blog teach learn grow
then i think that's where the motivation
comes from a lot of learned helplessness
with students comes when they've tried
and failed tried and failed and tried
and failed and so i like to
point back the educational system
sometimes and say if we have
i don't want to say we have unmotivated
learners i think that we always have
motivated learners they may just not be
motivated to do what we want them to do
so we have to really tap in and ask
ourselves
what are we doing to help students
see the return on investment to be
successful because that learned
hopelessness happens when students don't
see that return on investment or they
failed over and over after trying
so it's important to get early and easy
wins students have to experience success
the greatest predictor of future success
is past success success breeds success
so as teachers and as parents we have to
help our students get a win
and then they know what success feels
like and then they can crave it i always
like to say that chocolate and red wine
are two of my favorite things sal but i
never knew to crave those things until i
tried them and so the same thing is true
for students we have to give them a
little taste of success before they'll
want it on their own and we have we
might have to spoon feed it for a little
while and then eventually they're going
to take the spoon away and they're going
to feed themselves because they know
what it feels like and they know what it
takes to achieve it
now what i love is your statement about
there's no such thing as unmotivated
students i hear that all the time oh
this might be good for motivated
students but what about all of these
unmotivated students like it's like it's
in their dna or something and there's
not a
person on the planet who is not
you know i mean the video game industry
has figured out how to motivate people
uh there's a lot of things and i haven't
met a four or five-year-old who is an
incredibly curious and motivated you
have to fight them off you know they
want to explore everything they want to
ask you ten questions you're like i'm
done answering your questions please
give me a break
every four or five year old in the world
and so what your point is is that they
can become demotivated in certain
domains but once again it's not quote
their nature it's just a kind of a
learned helplessness ideally that
doesn't happen in the first place but
there's ways to de-program it by giving
them some wins you know we have a lab
school con lab school and there was a
open house that was and the teachers the
parents are always the prospective
parents are always like wait this is a
school without grades uh you know and i
remind them no no we have grades we
don't call them abcdf we could have but
we call them advanced mastery mastery
approaching mastery because they're for
mastery and the key is is that there's
always opportunity if a student is at
approaching mastery which you can kind
of view as a b
uh or or even a b minus that there's
always opportunities for them to improve
it so they never get the message that
it's somehow their innate you know
beingness or seenness of themselves uh
but it's just you know that's just where
they are right now if you're practicing
basketball you're a 60 free-throw
shooter it doesn't mean you're doomed to
never be better it's when you keep
practicing get to 80 get to 90
so i couldn't couldn't agree with that
more you know i was just on cbs this
morning yesterday and everyone said hey
this mckinsey study about all these kids
failing classes
i was like the key thing is we have to
give opportunities for these kids
especially because especially because
they're probably failing it based on
this kind of more completionist mindset
are they completing the assignments or
not uh we have to give these kids
opportunities frankly all kids when we
get back for them to make up the work
and show that they have mastery so that
it doesn't so it doesn't do the opposite
of what you just just described i agree
completely and i think what we've got to
do as a as an educational system in the
united states has challenged this idea
of the average as well
for me i think that
zeros are problematic and i think
averages are problematic and i think
that what we're really trying to
communicate is mastery then we should be
thinking about then how do our grades
reflect mastery and there's an
interesting research study out there
that actually shows that then the minute
you put a number grade on something the
learning stops for students
so i always when i'm working with
teachers really encourage them as long
as students are in the learning cycle
withhold that number
think about what kind of descriptive
feedback what kind of
actionable feedback can you provide that
will feed the learning forward and how
can you make time in your
in your classroom to for students to use
that feedback i hear all the time from
teachers well i write tons of things on
kids papers but they don't ever use they
don't ever use it my question is one are
you also including a grade and two are
you making explicit time for students to
to dig in and improve and in what ways
so if you're out there and you're you're
struggling um as a student or you are a
parent who has a child who's struggling
or you're a teacher who wants to dig in
and think about these things that's
where i'd ask you to start to really
start thinking about
what is it that i believe about
grades what is it that i believe about
student learning and what am i trying to
accomplish and how can we do that in a
way that empowers the learner to have
more of the locus of control and how do
we empower the learners at goals that
matter
and are meaningful and attainable and
then how can we be a support for that
and i really think that's our job as
parents i think that's our job as
teachers is to help cultivate these
individuals who will eventually be
empowered and can self-regulate and can
take charge and have the kinds of
futures that that they want for
themselves
no it's a it's a very very powerful idea
well brooke these conversations always
go much faster than i expect um
you know thanks so much for for joining
and uh you know i look forward to going
on this journey with you and nwea
because i think together we can help a
lot of
parents teachers and students stay in
that zone of proximal development
understanding what's working not working
make sure kids have a chance to master
concepts not just uh complete a few
things without mastery so so it's it's
really been an honor to talk to you
about this
thank you sal i appreciate the work and
i appreciate the partnership that we
have
thank you
well everyone uh thanks for joining uh
hopefully you enjoyed that conversation
uh some really interesting things to
think about actually i'm gonna think a
little bit about that notion when as
soon as you see the number uh it might
in certain ways uh stop some learning we
might might have to modify some things
on khan academy
we'll see we'll see about that uh we'll
see you tomorrow's uh a show we're gonna
have beth gonzalez who's the assistant
superintendent of detroit public schools
and you can imagine there's a lot of
interesting things to talk about when
you're talking to folks who are
administrators of large public school
systems like detroit so start thinking
of your questions and i will see you
tomorrow at 12 p.m pacific time 3 p.m
eastern
you